- Dua Lipa is sued by the paparazzi,
because she shared one
of the paparazzi's photos
of Dua Lipa.
This sounds ridiculous,
except for the fact that
Dua Lipa was the one
who was in the wrong.
We see this actually a lot,
where celebrities use a
photo that's taken of them,
thinking that they own the
intellectual property rights
related to it.
I think this happened to Miley
Cyrus and Brittany Spears.
The thing is it's the photographer
who owns the copyright
in the photo,
even if you take a photo of someone else.
Often the paparazzi have a
right to take these photos.
You could have two photographers
taking a picture of,
I don't know, a tree
and the photos could
look exactly the same.
They could be taken at
exactly the same time.
And each of those photographers
owns the copyright
in their particular photo.
And if you're taking a picture
of a person on the street,
it's not the person on the
street that owns that copyright.
It's the person that took the photo.
So just because you are
the subject of a photo,
doesn't mean that you have the copyright
and the ability to post
that photo on social media
and Dua Lipa found out the hard way
that she didn't own the rights.
So if we see Dua Lipa in court,
she's probably going to lose this one.